E
THAT'S A BIG PART OF THE PROBLEM
HERE IS OF HOW WE CAN HELP
AMERICANS FARMERS AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL BLACK
FARMERS ASSOCIATION JOHN
BOYD JR.
JOHN WELCOME ABOARD THINGS OR
BEING ON PROGRAM.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THANK YOU FOR
YOU DO I DON'T THINK WE GIVE
FARMERS ENOUGH CREDIT BECAUSE
EVERYTHING WE BUY IN OUR GROCERY
STORES COME FROM FARMERS AND
RANCHERS LIKE YOURSELF AND IT'S
NOT AN EASY PROFESSION I
UNDERSTAND THE MAY DISAGREE WITH
ME POLITICALLY THAT'S FINE TAKE
ME ANY ISSUE YOU WANT BY ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT FARMERS ARE
FACING BECAUSE NOT ONLY DO YOU
FEED THIS COUNTRY YOU FEED THE
WORLD ON TOP OF THIS COUNTRY AND
WE NEED AMERICAN FARMERS TO HAVE
EVERYTHING THEY NEED TO DO THEIR
GREAT JOB.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
TONIGHT.
RIGHT NOW OR IN A CRISIS IN
AMERICA AS IT RELATES TO
FARMERS.
ARE FACING AN ALL-TIME HIGH AND
DIESEL FUEL HERE IN VIRGINIA I'M
PAYING $5.63 A GALLON FOR DIESEL
FUEL, WERE AT AN HIGH FOR
FERTILIZER, I'M PAYING $900 A
TON.
THAT'S $900 A TON FOR FERTILIZER
$25,000 FERTILIZER BILL FIGURE
LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR AMERICA TO
COME TOGETHER AND SUPPORT
AMERICA'S FARMERS.
WE JUST PROVIDED RELIEF FOR
UKRAINE WERE WE TO BE LOOKING AT
SOME LOSSES THERE OF WHEAT AND
OTHER COMMODITIES WE JUST
PROVIDED UKRAINE WITH
$40 BILLION IN AID AND NOTHING
IN THAT SPENDING PACKAGE FOR
AMERICA'S FARMERS I KNOW THERE
ARE TRONIC GET SOME THINGS DONE
BUT AMERICA HAS TO COME BACK
TOGETHER.
AND WORK TOGETHER BY THE SAME
SCENE THAT'S DIVIDED RIGHT NOW.
WERE DIVIDED HERE IN OUR COUNTRY
ON RACE, BITTERNESS, AND HATRED.
LOVE IS ALWAYS GREATER THAN
HATE.
WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO WORK
TOGETHER SO THAT WE CAN GET
SOMETHING DONE AND THAT'S THE
AMERICAN.
>> Hannity: THIS IS MAYBE WHAT
WE PART WAYS POLITICALLY AND
THIS NO HATE IN MY VOICE HERE
THIS FRUSTRATION OF FEELING.
I'M FRUSTRATED THAT TWO-THIRDS
OF AMERICANS ARE LIVING PAYCHECK
TO PAYCHECK AND I BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S UNNECESSARY I BELIEVE
THAT GIVING UP AMERICAN ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE WITH ONE OF THE
DUMBEST THINGS OF THIS COUNTRY'S
EVER DONE BAKING ARE RAN,
VENEZUELA, THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO ME.
MAYBE YOU AGREE WITH THAT I
DON'T.
NOT FIXING THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
FERTILIZER FOR HARDWORKING
FARMERS LIKE YOU IS
UNCONSCIONABLE TO ME.
YOU FEED THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
>> YOU KNOW FARMERS OF THE LAST
ON THE TOTEM POLE AS IT COMES TO
GETTING RECOGNITION IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE MAY NOT BE A DOCTOR OR LAWYER
TODAY BUT EVERY DAY WE NEED AN
AMERICAN FARMER IN THIS COUNTRY
TO HELP THIS COUNTRY WE DON'T
GET THE RECOGNITION THAT WE NEED
AND AT THIS PARTICULAR TIME WERE
NOT GETTING THE SUPPORT THAT WE
NEED.
AS AFRICAN AMERICAN FARMERS AND
NATIONAL BLACK FARMERS
ASSOCIATION OUR MEMBERS ARE
WAITING FOR $5 BILLION AND AID
THAT WE DIDN'T GET FROM LAST
YEAR.
IT'S ALWAYS THE WAITING GAME BUT
THE EXAMPLE THAT I WAS MAKING
THAT WERE ABLE TO SWIFTLY
PROVIDE UKRAINE WITH $50 BILLION
I'M NOT AGAINST HELPING THAT
REGION OF THE COUNTRY AND THE
COST OF THE WAR AND THE EFFECTS
THE WAR AND ALL THAT TYPE OF
STUFF, BUT WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE
OF THOSE AT HOME.
>> Hannity: I AGREE WITH YOU.
I'M IN AMERICA FIRST GUY SO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO CONVINCE ME.
CAN I ASK YOU WHAT DO YOU FARM?
HOW MANY ACRES DO YOU FARM?
TO ME LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT YOU
DO EVERY DAY?
>> I'VE BEEN FARMING FOR 39
YEARS AND I'VE RAISED CORN,
SOYBEAN, HUNDRED HEADS OF BEEF
CATTLE.
I LIKE TO SAY I LIKE THEM TO PER
MOVE SWIFTLY TO PROVIDE AID TO
AMERICA'S FARMERS.
WHAT A SET OF THE TOP OF THE
SHOW WE HAD A CRISIS AND WERE IN
A CRISIS IN AMERICA AMERICA
ALWAYS FINDS A WAY TO RISE UP
OVER ALL OF THE OBSTACLES THAT'S
IN FRONT OF US.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO
RIGHT NOW FOR AMERICA'S FARMERS.
IF WE DON'T DO THAT HAVE YOU
BEEN TO THE GROCERY STORE
LATELY?
I'M ASKED THAT QUESTION.
LOOK AT THE PRICES IN TODAY'S
GROCERY STORES.
THEY ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
RISE IF WE DON'T FIX THE
PROBLEM SO WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
GET OUR CROPS IN THE GROUND
RIGHT NOW AND WITH THE PRESIDENT
WAS TALKING ABOUT PROVIDING AID
IN FEDERAL CROPPING I'VE BEEN
FARMING FOR 39 YEARS IF I'VE THE
CHOICE BETWEEN FEDERAL INSURANCE
AND BUYING SEED AND FERTILIZER,
BY SEEDS AND FERTILIZER EVERY
TIME.
EVERY TIME PEOPLE.
NOW IS THE TIME TO MOVE SWIFTLY
AND TO ACT PRECISELY TO GET
AMERICA'S FARMERS THE AID THAT
THEY NEED AND DESERVE TO PLANT
THEIR CROPS ON TIME.
WE HAVE A 30 DAY WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY SUPPLANT OUR CROPS
THIS YEAR.
ANY TIME OFF THAT ANY FARMER CAN
TELL YOU IT IS SO WISH AND A
GAMBLE AFTER THAT.
SO WE NEED THE AID MANY OF OUR
BACK BLACK FARMERS RIGHT NOW
DON'T HAVE FARM OPERATING LOANS
IN PLACE.
DIDN'T GET THEIR DEBT RELIEF
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO GET IN THE
USDA SUPPORTING THESE FARMERS AS
DELINQUENTS.
DESTROY STRUGGLING TRYING TO GET
THE FORMS READY.
WE AS FARMERS NEED
INFRASTRUCTURE, CORPORATE 500
COMPANIES HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH TO
HELP AMERICA'S FARMERS
COMPLETELY JOHN DEERE.
THEY SHOULD BE CUTTING INTEREST
RATES AT THIS TIME FOR FARMERS
AND ALL THESE COMPANIES THAT
WANT TO GET BIGGER.
TELL US HOW THEY CAN HELP THE
AMERICAN FARMER HERE?
>> Hannity: WANT TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR FELLOW FARMERS FOR ALL
THE GREAT WORK YOU DO.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Hannity: I WISH YOU THE
BEST.
YOU FEED ALL OF US AND YOU DON'T
GET ENOUGH CREDIT FOR IT